this week we've got PB pump sticky
situation and life of poultry
oh no let's stick to the first one yeah
focus do he be pump yep peanut butter
power now you put peanut butter on your
dick and then you pump the [ __ ] out of
some like this [ __ ] literally the show
yeah yeah like in the booty home PB pump
look that is damn so this is an
IndieGoGo you ready buddy all right babe
don't get stuck
it's an IndieGoGo right now so I'm not
gonna get into like okay how do you want
never learn it's also really don't
because you like pieces scrape down as
you pump yes and it's like a clean
bottle yeah it's like that male one with
the thought leave it it's clean wow
that's amazing sarcastic no I'm not
being sarcastic this is fit all brands
well whatever size all the brands I have
the same size chart okay straight up the
most shitty thing about peanut butter is
that when you're done with it you're not
really done cuz it's so much [ __ ] in
there and you have to go in there put
your hand in it like Winnie the Pooh
getting honey with a [ __ ] piece of
Hawaiian bread oh you're a lot smarter
than I am ice cream in it I never
finished the peanut but that's really
smart
that sounds bomb I know but I want you
to know I wasn't being sarcastic
genuinely excited peanut butter always
just disappeared at my house without me
knowing that it's done I just always had
a fresh new one eat like some and it
just disappeared but how do you how do
you live you never know where anything
goes or comes from or haven't even here
we said he was talking about how when he
never knows when it disappears every
time he opens it it's a huge I never got
to that point where the peanut butter is
at the very end that's a good point yeah
I just open it I take it I cut it
there's a new peanut butter thing no
that's true or sore like or like ketchup
all my life it's been that way because
ketchups is always there you know I use
it to the bottoms I could think of one
occasion why remember pushing the
ketchup and got our weenie a new bottle
and then a new one appears I've never
been so excited about something that
might fail when it comes out it is gonna
fail but you can't use chunky in there
then it's only a mean chunky chunky
works chunky you're about almond butter
I like chunky if the bottle fit please
know I'm about this tiny huh what is it
called the peanut the peanut butter pump
peanut butter jelly time huh
so I was twenty five bucks for me to
order this on IndieGoGo damn big [ __ ]
expensive like how do you paint it
though that's a good question I don't
know yet I don't think you have to homie
you just keep it on right but for peanut
butter all day I guess do you even know
me no I don't know what you do at home I
live but you don't even eat that's why I
don't know that's what you do because
I've been wondering what you eat she's
full Annette yeah you're a mother now
this is the first time I've heard of
your peanut butter obsession what yeah
her baby's Reese's Pieces she told you
that Reese's Pieces is different it's
candy I don't consider that peanut
butter it's peanut butter flavor boy
he's not real peanut butter yeah listen
when you talk about peanut butter jelly
sandwich no I have talked about how I
scoop up peanut butter with the spoon
and I just sit there and I snack on a
spoonful of peanut butter forever oh no
about I mean I didn't know about peanut
butter did I peanut butter has been with
me since day one
uh he was new Tajin on to your peanut
butter yeah you crave you don't know
anything about her dude what's salty and
spicy and sweet why not I should try it
you ever done like a peanut butter and
bacon sandwich oh that sounds bomb hoppy
peanut butter banana have you tried that
yes that's my main sliced banana every
single morning
have you had Ritz Rhino butter with
bananas drivers with wing [ __ ] peanut
butter and then jelly and in another
Ritz cracker
so peanut butter jelly the sandwich
Veronica exactly my grandma choose
roasted or just peanut butter that's how
much I love peanut butter I'll never
have private jelly on my penis my
grandma was a horrible cook because she
always tried to invent some [ __ ] but
this one was pretty [ __ ] bomb alright
so you get butter put it on one end you
get peanut butter put it on the other
fire two on the butter and you get brown
sugar you sprinkle that [ __ ] you
slice some bananas put that in the
middle try that on for size
try that on for size try that opal
Elvis's favorite sandwich was peanut
butter bananas and bacon yes I heard
about that it is bomb I try to I made it
home and Elvis is a pedophile okay he's
known for I like is mean I wish peanut
butter was healthier for you no calorie
dense oh man it's so fatty it's not a
healthy snack it's one of the worst
things you can it's full of sugar it's a
high in sugar high in fat yeah high
calories yeah it's super high it's
literally everything that's bad for you
and one has enough to like pack with
nice to do macros and I needed my fat it
was perfect yeah but it's negligible the
protein is negligible y'all ever put a
peanut butter or just peanut peanut my
jelly in a tortilla roll it up make a
little one out
oh let me not do that yeah flour
tortilla Peter but nah nah I used to do
that and um and you fry it no no I did
it I did it one time and some girl
looked at me crazy she's like ill in a
tortilla it sounded to be good it's not
jelly it looks like white yelling at me
for like a tortilla basically just
[ __ ] flat ass bread you know I was
like quesadilla is a chess sandwich
little flavor to it though that felt
like it wouldn't pair well with a corn
tortilla will be man that was me with
the flour I should try it then people
just kind of open
- in the world over - a man she just
started cooking she'll be I'm nothing
about her I'm talking about her
I put peanut butter and jelly in a
tortilla right I sprinkle [ __ ] cereal
on it okay
like cinnamon toast crunch or like some
like cornflakes or whatever and I roll
it up add some texture let me not do
that and fire as a [ __ ] texture did I
detect an idea for flour tortilla put
some butter on that [ __ ]
sprinkle some cinnamon put some brown
sugar put some maple syrup a little bit
cuz you already got the brown sugar then
you [ __ ] put that on a on a pan yeah
that's probably good like it's like a
constant beer and that scoop of vanilla
ice cream on top oh you really put it to
the next level there yeah that's what I
do you blue is my dude I'm hungry now
I went from like that's a churro
- now that's a chiral split that's what
you all right anyway so this pump here
it comes with two attachments so it has
like this ribbon kind for sandwiches
looks like that I wonder if little pump
is jealous whoa the fact that it pushes
the whole beam down you need to be a
power lifter to make that [ __ ] he uses
some sort of technology with like the
airlock or some [ __ ] and because it like
it's negative pressure with the air or
something I don't know he invents it we
even have it if you someone stuck a
spoon all the way in pulling it out as I
sword in the stone mm-hmm so to move the
whole thing down yeah there's our video
it was he just going like this easily
yeah Tiffany I'll show you the video
okay smart dude I don't care next topic
too late because I mean whoa wow that
thing is well-made you like jam or jelly
I don't even know the difference I'd
rather just have seen a better fighter
nah I can't have what just did he put it
in that microwave jelly with this no no
that's what people think that this is
fake that the peanut butter is watered
down or it's hot but the inventor is
like no you just dance
by jelly is kind of like jello texture
yeah and jam is more like just fruit
pureed that's goopy but it's like I like
Jam I like both yeah give me both but
jelly is easier for the sandwiches cuz
it spreads easier yeah for jam is just
like you might have a glob of strawberry
on one side and just liquid on the other
but I don't mind that it still give
that's my jam moving on to the next
story this man this man got stuck in
peanut butter
no no um so he created this coffee bar
countertop that he like cut himself and
he sanded it and he stained it all real
nice and then he put a coat of epoxy
resin mm-hmm one day when he got out of
the shower he was just he kind of
touched to the the counter he was like
oh yeah it seems like it's hardened and
it's pretty good so he sat on it oh Lord
so cuz he was gonna he was reading the
instructions for the epoxy wondering if
he should give it another coat so that's
when like he's thinking you just sat on
it make it naked after the shower his
balls and ass got stuck so then oh when
he was gonna get up he was just like oh
[ __ ] he got stuck huh he went on reddit
has the smoothest [ __ ] balls and ass
now Oh how'd he let it dry out for he
said that he put it on Thursday night
but I'm not sure which night he posted
on reddit or like when he got stuck but
I think it was more than 24 hours cuz he
said that it was supposed to set hard in
24 hours hmm so I'm thinking he did wait
at least 24 hours heat and moisture from
the shower like made it wet again and
while it's sitting on it be the next go
to hmm okay
it's a counter - he did call a
non-emergency like online or whatever so
he was waiting for them to return his
phone call and so as he was waiting he
went on reddit he was just like oh my
god what do I do
maybe I should take one of those girls
selfies what they put that ass cheek I'm
gonna sink and then tank so make sure a
bigger photo this is the photo you
posted he did after like all these
comments they were like 300 comments and
he put more [ __ ] on the [ __ ] counter
well hold on let me explain this okay so
after like 300 comments people were like
oh no and someone said damn what a
pickle and that's when the guy was like
oh that's genius I could use the vinegar
from the pickle jar that's it within
reach that I can get he did have like
uber and stuff like he did have other
solutions in his garage that would help
him get out but all you need an acid to
get off of that epoxy yeah but because
he couldn't fit through the door to get
to his garage he was like oh [ __ ] the
vinegar and the pickle jar imagine all
he had to do was just turn this way to
fit through the door well this was the
counter he was on so he was able to get
damn she's kind of nice he was able to
get loose enough from the pickle juice
man to reach over to the saw like he had
and he cut himself oh well not himself
but he cut the table to get himself read
he was that stuck yeah that's crazy they
say you can do butt cheeks on here but I
don't know where I think he couldn't
those I don't know maybe it was these I
don't know man what would you put an
epoxy glaze on that [ __ ] beautiful
wood dude I like it maybe saw shines is
it to protect it or there's other things
makes it waterproof and [ __ ] like that
but it doesn't look good that reminds me
of the days when I used to make my own
furniture
remember my beautiful cinderblock TV
stand the word beautiful is shouldn't be
attached that [ __ ] though artistic oh
you were trying to be all industrial and
[ __ ] yeah and then Tyson would pee next
to it and the cinderblock would soak up
all the people
oh my god no like bumpass inside your
living room yeah all the time
yeah and then human piss right outside
the doorway he would piss on the [ __ ]
brick wall hey that's not part of the
school I like color switch because the
dog was supposed to be pissing off it
seems heavy ball you confuse a dog he's
like well I guess I got to piss his
voice too by the way he's walked out C's
buck alright put the dog dick away our
last story today now have GPS trackers
on chickens
why we can't really eat him so you could
know where your chicken came from and
exactly what your chicken did I thought
it was like you have free-range chickens
that go around your whole tyre village
and you're like where are my tickets go
now I'm hungry because you know like you
know why there's chickens everywhere
who's like where my chickens go man I'm
hungry dude I gotta eat my chicken
Kawai apparently there's more chickens
than there are people on the island that
you'll never go hungry yeah they're all
over the [ __ ] place man it's unreal
so wait what what what why do they want
this so they are who cares they have
some of it right here GPS trackers in
China so a Chinese insurance comfort oh
it's like make sure that they were they
were actually there changing they lie
they put these trackers on a hundred
thousand chicken and so these sensors
they upload information such as like how
much exercise the chicken got what got
bits on the chicken what the chicken ate
so cute and so there that company is
saying that they will be in two thousand
five hundred farms in China by next year
it's awesome and that they're also
working on facial recognition technology
so then the customers can make sure that
the organic chicken that they saw on the
farm is the exact same one that ends up
on a plate I'm sorry that wild like the
Portlandia episode when they wanted to
know everything about their chicken
there and then they find out that the
chickens name was Colin but that's oh
that
ha sheisty [ __ ] china is that they
even have to step in and be like alright
you [ __ ] like way too much we
gotta take extreme measures yes these
insurance companies that could be lower
risk for them so is it like a common
thing in China to go investigate where
you're like chickens are coming from
before you I think there's more
health-conscious people now like than
before because I mean there's been cases
where like people are buying tuna or
whatever and then there's like mercury
or lead to make the fish way more so
they could sell the fish for higher baby
formula right baby for it they put chalk
and babe oh so they could make it way
more God or like yeah there's a lot of
they just want to know that their food
is coming from a good source there's
like a lot of millionaires they're like
there's like in one city I heard there's
like 2 million millionaires or some [ __ ]
like that
hmm well there's a lot of [ __ ] people
yeah that actually have money that care
about where their food comes from so I
think they're more like cautious it's
like oh it came from this farm it that
that will work good here too because I
mean like it's good to know where your
your food you know I don't like that I
just had a grass-fed beef grass-fed bisa
is not that there's not I can't say I've
had it now it's so is hyper lean and it
has a very interesting taste
like did not like it and it's [ __ ]
like three times the price is regular
corn-fed beef so [ __ ] it Joe Rogan also
they probably didn't finish it off right
too because there's places that are
grass-fed and delicious like Snake River
farms where all the best
Shabba meat comes from mmm but when they
they're supposed to have this like carb
high diet at the very end where it's
grainy and then they finish it that way
and then it tastes nice and sweet
interesting [ __ ] was not good man but
all grass-fed a lot of money free-range
super lean super nasty I don't like it
oh god yeah give me a fat cow man yeah I
want that one they're supposed to die
and the one that's like being bred to oh
yeah just delicious
well like a Kobe beef right the most the
most fattiest fattiest like Wagyu Co
baby
like they get [ __ ] beer everyday like
if you see if you see the way that
they're treated they're treating them
better than some other [ __ ] human
beings here yeah they get massage dance
every day dude every day they just chill
in a [ __ ] little box and indeed
hampered nobody looks really in a box
though I know hope you want a cuz he
can't move too much but they're being
massaged for hours and they get drunk
for hours every day they're getting fed
good they get like they get like
different kind of like like massages too
like they have this big-ass rope that
they wrap around their body and they
just rub it and they're just like oh
[ __ ] yeah then they get happy endings
yeah yeah to it yeah they don't know
they're gonna get eaten though
nah don't even know what that means if
my whole existence was just get a
massage and get high every [ __ ] day
and then I die that's kind of cool the
whole time you don't get any Sun that
you don't get anything but if you don't
know what the world is about know that
you do you do you do get a sunlight if
they're outside they're outside they're
outdoors you get so they get to see that
they get to see it from their box they
need to see the world maybe get to see
how shitty the other cows have it
they're outdoors like me there's there's
videos of how they're like raised so
they keep them in the boxes so they
don't use too much of their like muscles
yeah so they don't walk around too much
and even give them a couch to hmm get
the QQ Velma wait let's get some burgers
sometimes when we do those the food show
stuff I don't want them to bring the
animals first so we could see them like
I've been watching a lot of piglet
videos they're so cute they're cute huh
does not make me want to eat pork I was
just telling Gio that when we went to
the frog leg festival afterwards
remember they had me played with a
little frog and I was like mm-hmm
I don't like this cuz I was like my
cousin earlier
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]